okay let's take you back to New York
where world leaders have gathered for
the United Nations General Assembly
Brazil's president Luis enacio Lula de
Silva is speaking now let's listen in
and delegates present
I pay homage to our compatriot Sergio
Viera de Merlo and 21 other employees of
this organization victims of the brutal
attack in Baghdad 20 years ago
I also wish to express my condolences to
the victims of the earthquake in Morocco
and the storms that hit Libya
like what happened recently in the state
of Rio Grande OSU in my country these
tragedies have claimed lives and causing
irreparable losses our thoughts and
prayers are with all the victims and
their families if you're join us ladies
and gentlemen exactly 20 years ago I
stood on this Rostrum for the first time
and said On That September 23rd 2003 my
first words before this world Parliament
be of confidence in the human capacity
to overcome challenges and evolve
towards Superior forms of coexistence I
returned today to say that I maintain my
unshakable trust in humanity at that
time the world had not yet realized the
severity of the climate crisis today it
knocks on our doors destroys our homes
our cities our countries kills and
imposes losses and suffering on our
brothers especially the poorest
hunger the central theme of my speech at
this world Parliament 20 years ago today
affects
735 million human beings who will go to
sleep this tonight without knowing if
they'll have anything to eat tomorrow
the world is increasingly unequal the 10
richest billionaires have more wealth
than the poorest 40 percent of humanity
the destiny of every child born on this
planet seems to be decided while they're
still in their mother's womb the part of
the world where their parents live and
the social class their family belongs to
will determine whether or not that child
will have opportunities throughout life
whether they will eat at every meal or
whether they will be denied the right to
eat breakfast lunch and dinner every day
whether they will have access to health
care or whether they will fall to
diseases that could have already been
eradicated
whether they will finish school and get
a quality job or whether they will
become part of the countless of
unemployed underemployed and
discouraged people
first of all we must overcome
resignation which makes us accept such
unfairness as a natural phenomenon
to overcome inequality there's a lack of
political will from those who govern the
worlds in order to overcome inequality
ladies and gentlemen if today I return
in The Honorable capacitor president of
Brazil it is thanks to the victory won
by democracy in my country democracy
ensured that we overcame hate
misinformation and oppression hope once
again has won over fear our mission is
tonight Brazil and rebuild a sovereign
Fair sustainable supportive with
solidarity generous and a joyful country
Brazil's finding itself again with
itself with our region with the world
and multilateralism
as I never Tire of repeating Brazil is
back our country is back to make its due
contributions
in facing the major global
[Applause]
is
our country is back to make its true
contributions in facing the major Global
challenges
got thermals we have reclaimed our
foreign policies universalism marked by
respectful dialogue with everyone the
International Community is immersed in a
whirlwind of multiple and simultaneous
crisis the Kofi 19 pandemic the climate
crisis the food and energy insecurity
have been Amplified by growing
geopolitical tensions racism intolerance
xenophobia have spread
encouraged by new technologies created
supposedly to bring us closer together
if we had to civilize these challenges
in a single word this challenge could be
called the reason for its challenge
would be inequality inequality is at the
root of this phenomenon or acts to
aggravate them
the un's brought us a most ambitious
Collective action aimed at development
the 2030 agenda could turn into its
biggest favor we have reached half of
the implementation period and are still
far from the defined goals
of the sustainable development goals are
moving at a slow place
the moral and political imperative of
eradicating poverty and ending hunger
appears to have been numbed
in these seven years that we have left
reducing their qualities within and
between countries should become the core
objective of the 2030 agenda reducing
inequalities within countries requires
including the poor in government budgets
and making the rich pay taxes that are
proportional to their wealth in Brazil
we are committed to implementing all the
sdgs in an integratively adopt
yeah
we won't say for me we launched the
Brazil zero hunger plan which will bring
together a series of initiatives to
reduce poverty and food insecurity
amongst them is the bossa Familia the
family stipend which has become a global
reference in income transfer programs
for families that keep their children
vaccinated and in school
inspired by Brazilian Bertha loots a
pioneer as an advocate in gender
equality in the U.N Charter we have
passed a bill that makes equal pay
between women and men mandatory when
they perform the same role
foreign
against women we shall rigorously
advocate for the rights of the
lgbtqi plus groups and of people with
disabilities we have revived social
participatory practices as a strategic
tool for implementing public policies Mr
President
acting against climate change involves
thinking about tomorrow and facing
historical inequalities rich countries
grew based on a model with high rates of
climate damage and gas emissions
the climate emergency makes it urgent to
correct course and Implement what has
already been agreed there's no other
reason why we speak of common but
differentiated responsibilities it is
the vulnerable populations in the global
South who are most affected by a loss
and damage caused by climate change the
richest 10 of the world's population are
responsible for almost half of all
carbon released into the atmosphere
developing countries do not want to
repeat this model number view in Brazil
we have already proven once and we'll
prove again that a socially fair and
environmentally sustainable model is
possible we are at the Forefront of
energy transition and our Matrix is
already one of the cleanest in the world
87 of our electrical power comes from
clean and renewable sources
solar wind biomass ethanol and biodiesel
power generation is growing every year
the potential for generating green
hydrogen is immense with the ecological
transformation plan we will invest in
sustainable industrialization and
sustainable infrastructure we have
resumed the sound and renewed Amazon
agenda with oversight actions
aimed at fighting environmental crimes
over the last eight months
fire station in the Brazilian Amazon has
already been reduced by 48 percent the
world the whole world has always talked
about the Amazon
he has always talked about the Amazon
now the Amazon is speaking for itself
a month ago we hosted that the name
Summit meeting at the heart of the
Amazon and launched a new collaboration
agenda between countries that are part
of that biome there are 50 million South
Americans in living in the Amazon whose
future depends on the the size of
incarnation action of the countries that
hold sovereignty over the Region's
territories we all have also further
dialogue with other countries that have
tropical forests in Africa and Asia we
want to arrive at cope 28 in Dubai with
a joint Vision that reflects without any
coaching the priorities for preserving
the Amazon the Congo and Borneo Mekong
basins based on our needs
without mobilizing financial and
technological resources there's no way
to implement what we decided in the
Paris agreement and the global prior
diversity framework the promise to it
allocate a hundred billion dollars
annually to developing countries remains
just that
promise a long promise today this amount
would be insufficient for a demand that
already reaches
trillions of dollars Mr President
the principle on which multilateralism
is based that of sovereign equality
between nations have been eroding at the
main Global governance levels
negotiations in which all countries have
a voice and vote have lost momentum
when institution reproducing their
qualities they are part of the problem
not the solution last year the IMF made
available
160 billion dollars in special drawing
rights to European countries
34 billion to African countries
and equal and distracted representation
the management of the IMF and the World
Bank is unacceptable we have not
corrected the excesses of Market
deregulation and the support of the and
the ideology of the minimum State the
foundations of the new economic
Governors have not been late the brics
was the result of this paralysis and
constitute a strategic platform to
promote cooperation between emerging
countries
the regional expansion of the group at
the Johannesburg Summit meeting
strengthens the fight for an order which
accommodates the economic Geographic and
political plurality of the 21st century
we are a force that works towards fairer
global trade in the context of a serious
crisis in multimateralism
which country's protectionisms have
gained has gained strength in the World
Trade Organization remains paralyzed
especially its dispute settlement system
nobody remembers the Doha development
round anymore
in the meantime unemployment and
precarious work I mean that has been
undermining people's confidence in
better times
especially the youth
governments need to break away
from the increasing dissonance between
the voice of the markets and the voice
of the streets
neoliberalism has aggravated the
economic and political inequality that
plagues democracies today its Legacy is
a mass of disenfranchise and excluded
people amidst the wreck far-right
Adventures emerge who deny politics and
Sell Solutions that are easy as they are
wrong
many have fallen to the temptation of
replacing failed and neoliberalism with
primitive conservative and authoritarian
nationalism
foreign
agenda that uses immigrants as
scapegoats
undermines the welfare state and attacks
workers rights
we need to reclaim the best humanist
Traditions which Inspire the creation of
the UN
no relevant economical Society active
inclusion policies at cultural education
and digital levels are fundamental for
promoting democratic values and
defending the rule of law
it is preserving press freedom is
essential a journalist like Julian
Assange cannot be punished
informing Society in a transparent and
legitimate way
our fight is against misinformation and
cyber crimes
and platforms should not abolish the
labor laws we've fought so hard for
upon taking over as the chair of the G20
next December we will spare no effort to
place the fight against inequality in
all its Dimensions at the core of the
international agenda Under The Motto
building a just world and a sustainable
Planet the president's chair will
coordinate social inclusion and fight
against hunger sustainable development
and reform of global governance
institutions Mr President
there will be no sustainability or
Prosperity without peace armed conflicts
are an offense to human rationality
we know the horrors and suffering
produced by all wars promoting a culture
of peace is a duty for all of us
the building it requires persistence and
vigilance it is disturbing to see that
old unresolved disputes persist and new
threats emerge or gain Force
the difficulty of guaranteeing the
creation of a state for the Palestinian
people clearly shows this added to this
case the persevering humanitarian crisis
in Haiti the conflict
threats to Libya National unity and
institutional ruptures in Burkina FASA
Guatemala there's a risk of the coup
d'etat which would prevent the winner
the Democratic elections from taking
office the Warren in Ukraine exposes our
Collective inability to enforce the
purposes and principles of the U.N
Charter no we do not underestimate the
difficulties in achieving peace but no
solution will be lasting if it is not
based on dialogue I have reiterated that
work needs to be done to create space
for negotiations
Allah is invested in weapons and very
little in development last year military
spending total over two trillion dollars
expenditures on nuclear weapons reach 83
billion dollars a value 20 times higher
than the regular U.N budget
stability and security no will not be
achieved where there is social exclusion
and inequality the U.N was born to be
the home of understanding dialogue The
International Community must choose on
one hand there is the expansion of
conflicts the furthering of inequalities
and the erosion of the rule of law on
the other the renewing of multilateral
Institutions dedicated to promoting
peace I feel fight unilateral sanctions
cause great harm to the population of
affected countries
in addition to not achieving their
alleged goals they came to the mediation
and prevention processes
and the police vote resolution of
conflicts Brazil will continue to reject
measures taken without support from the
U.N Charter such as the economic and
financial embargoing post on Cuba and
the attempt to classify this country as
a state sponsor of terrorism
we shall continue to criticize any
attempts to divide the world into zones
of influence and Reviving The Cold War
the U.N security Council has been
progressively losing its credibility
this Frailty is the specific result of
actions from its permanent members who
wage unauthorized Wars and their
territorial expansion or regime change
it's paralysis is the most eloquent
proof of the urgent need to reform it
which will bring it Greater
representation and efficacy ladies and
gentlemen
inequalities needs to inspire Inspire
outrage outrage over Hunger poverty War
disrespect for human beings
moved by the power of outrage and we may
act willingly and unwavering in fighting
inequality and effectively transforming
the world around us the U.N that needs
to fulfill its role as a builder of a
world with more solidarity fraternity
and fairness but if it would only do so
if its members have the courage to
Proclaim their discontent at inequality
and work tirelessly to overcome it and I
will just to say thank you very much to
all of you
foreign